[Musik]
vor fast genau einem Jahr startete Putin
den Angriff auf die Ukraine schon über
7.000 Zivilisten sind in diesem Krieg
ums Leben gekommen dazu auf beiden
Seiten zehntausende Tote Soldaten und
Verletzte die Ukraine leben nun seit
zwölf Monaten mit dieser Bedrohung und
die kommenden sechs Monate die könnten
laut Experten entscheidend in diesem
Krieg sein lange hat der Westen gezögert
jetzt sollen sie der Ukraine helfen
Kampfpanzer geliefert auch aus deutschen
Beständen die Forderung aus Kiew im
Anschluss westliche Kampfjets und
weitere Waffensysteme um die eigene
Position zu stärken
wenn die Waffenlieferungen beschleunigt
werden auch Waffen mit großer Reichweite
werden wir bachmut halten können und den
Donbass befreit
zeitgleich wachsen die Spannungen
zwischen den Großmächten USA und China
ein mutmaßlicher chinesischer
spionageballon wird über den USA
gesichtet US-Außenminister blinken sagt
seine China-Reise kurzfristig ab die
Präsenz dieses überwachungsbalance im
US-Luftraum ist eine klare Verletzung
der us-souveränität und des Völkerrechts
das ist eine unverantwortliche Handlung
während sich der Graben zwischen China
und den USA vertieft zerstören russische
Raketen die Ukraine weiter ich war im
Schlafzimmer und hörte ein Knall dann
tat es weh und alles wurde dunkel
rundherum alles zerstört
ein Jahr Krieg in der Ukraine wie
verändert Putins Angriff die Welt
und damit herzlich willkommen zum
internationalen Frühschoppen heute mit
diesen Gästen bei uns ist Catherine
Klüver ashbruck sie ist Publizistin und
Analystin bei der Bertelsmannstiftung
und bei uns ist Udo lidschkis er ist
Journalist und ehemaliger ARD
moskau-korrespondent herzlich willkommen
Sergej zum Lenny Publizist und bei uns
ist Chemie freier Journalist und
Publizist herrschi eigentlich wäre ja
heute der US-Außenminister blinken zu
Gast in China gewesen aufgrund des
mutmaßlichen chinesischen
spionageballons ist dieser Besuch
abgesagt worden was war da los und was
bezweckt China mit diesem Spiel
mutmaßlichen Spionage
ich denke die China beabsichtigte in
erster Linie ein Handlungsfähigkeit
globalen Ausmaßes zu markieren china
möchte nicht gerne in die Rolle
zurückgedrängt werden als würde es nur
und Taiwan gehen und gerade diese
Handlungsfähigkeit in globalen Ausmaßen
wäre auch wenn chinesische Hilfe für
Putin in Russland sozusagen wir gucken
uns nicht nur Asien an wir gucken auch
weltweit an wir fordern sofort die USA
an aber auch diese Ballon ist ein
wohlkalkuliertes Risiko Ballon ist nicht
wirklich eine Waffe oder direkt nicht
Ballon ist eher ein soft-symbol wir sind
handlungsfähig aber wir sind noch nicht
im Flugzeug äh handlungsfähig wir sind
noch nicht mit Raketen handlungsfähig
ähm also das ist wohl kalkuliert was man
aber nicht kalkulierte hatte oder
vielleicht auch hatten können ist ähm
dass diese Ballon nicht nur jetzt in den
USA eingedrungen sind jetzt laute
us-kongresse Informationen sind schon
drei
flugballons über die USA hinweg geflogen
während der Amtszeit von Donald Trump
also es ist ein regelmäßiger Handlung so
dass sind das denn also die chinesische
Seite sagt ja das sind Ballons um
meteorologische Daten zu sammeln ist das
Quatsch also mittlerweile ist der Ballon
ja abgeschossen das heißt man wird es
vermutlich rausfinden können wie was
halten Sie denn von der chinesischen
Argumentation
die Argumentation hat etwas
denn es gibt ja wirklich solche Balance
die für wettedienste eingesetzt werden
es ist nicht ganz aus der aus der Luft
gegriffen worden ob es wirklich diese
Balance sind das ist ein andere Frage
vor einigen ob es wirklich in diese
Regelmäßigkeit passiert ist es ein
anderer und außerdem wenn dieser Ballons
die chinesische Seite sagte er gerät
außer Kontrolle die Ballons sollten
eigentlich gar nicht in die USA
gesichtet werden können sondern man
könne eben die Wind nicht steuern und
deswegen sind die Balance abgewichen
wenn also viermal hintereinander die
selber Ballons immer abgewichen sind und
immer in die Richtung USA und diese sehr
sehr weniger plausibel das ist nur das
Windes
wegen passiert und ich denke
wahrscheinlich rechnet man doch damit
dass die Welt Öffentlichkeit so nicht
glaubt aber was
beabsichtigt wir sind handlungsfähig wir
sind militärisch doch ein zu etwas fähig
ein Zeichen ein klares Zeichen aus China
in den USA folklog ist das ja sehr
diskutiert jetzt hätte beiden schneller
an ihren müssen hätte der ja Abschluss
schneller erfolgen müssen ja der
Präsident hat schon Mittwoch beschlossen
dass dieser Ballon abgeschossen werden
sollte und das natürlich vorher
gesichtet werden sollte mit welcher
Technologie dieser Ballon ausgerüstet
ist ob man ihn blockieren kann die
Technologie ist so relativ schnell von
den amerikanischen vom Hintergrund
blockiert worden also die Sensorik die
einen Ballon dieser Art gebraucht und
dann hat er sich beraten lassen vom
Pentagon und die sagten noch mal weil
diese Technologie der unterhingen wie
ein Zeppelin das Ausmaß hätte von drei
riesengroßen Schulbussen dass das
natürlich nicht über Land in den USA
hätte herunterkommen können also eine
Kalkulation das über dem Wasser absegeln
zu lassen vorher zu versuchen die
Technologie zu blockieren das war glaube
ich schlau das wird sich auch so
herausstellen muss die Republikaner
vermutlich auch auch preisgeben die sehr
sehr viel innenpolitischen Druck gemacht
haben jetzt kriegen der Republikaner
gesagt dass unter Trump drei weitere
dieser Balance über den USA kreisten
also da verändert sich auch gerade ein
bisschen das innenpolitische Kalkül und
vermutlich schlägt das Herrn beiden
zugute glauben Sie dass es wirklich so
von chinesischer Seite veranschlagt
wurde dass man diesen Besuch von blinken
wirklich auch gar nicht unbedingt wollte
doch der Besuch wird gewollt der Besuch
wird auch stattfinden ich gehe davon aus
dass er in den nächsten Wochen oder
nächsten Monaten stattfinden wird es ist
insofern man kann so auslegen oder so
auslegen man könnte sagen dass abdriften
des Ballons im Kontext zum Beispiel mit
der Ankündigung dass es neue ausgebaute
Militärbasen auf den Philippinen geben
soll der Amerikaner um ein Zeichen gegen
China im Umkreis Chinas zu setzen und
dass das dann als Antwort kommt also das
entweder sieht man das in dieser
Sequenzierung oder man sieht es in der
Sequenzierung zum Besuch also ich glaube
das Timing ist ungünstig im Großen und
Ganzen für die chines das ist dennoch
ein Zeichen und eine Fragestellung kann
Amerika reagieren auf Eintritte in ihren
eigenen Luftraum während sie eingebunden
sind in großen Fragen in den in der
Ukraine und den anderen großen globalen
Umständen sind und sind und bleibt die
USA weiterhin handlungsfähig und sofern
ist dieser dieser Art des Umgangs des
Präsident natürlich ein ganz klares
Signal auch das kann die USA aber das
heißt nicht dass es nicht auch ein
diplomatischen das ist nicht ein
diplomatisches erweitertes Nachspiel
haben werden muss und das reiht sich
natürlich in die Größe und
geopolitischen Fragen ein die USA und
China zusammen lösen müssen also ein
Zeichen schon von chinesischer Stärke
wie beurteilen Sie das Handy was hat das
für eine Auswirkung jetzt auf dem Krieg
in der Ukraine
ja dass die spannende Frage ich weiß
auch nicht was in den Ballon war
irgendwie spekulieren hier ja auch mit
teilweise mit beschränkter Fakten Menge
ich fand interessant was die NZZ schrieb
die neue Züricher Zeitung nämlich dass
es vor kurzer Zeit noch einen Versuch
von William burns gab doch noch einmal
auszuloten kann man Kiew überreden im
Tausch gegen die Abgabe von Land das
sind da jetzt 18 % glaube ich
Verhandlungen zuzustimmen
friedensverhandlung und auch Moskau und
das soll gescheitert sein wir wissen
alle nicht ob das so zutrifft aber ich
glaube es gibt in Washington durchaus
einen Flügel der mit gebremster
Begeisterung das Engagement der USA in
der Ukraine sieht der klammheimlich ohne
es erlaubt zu sagen schon mit dem
Gedanken die bräugelt Lachen schnell zu
einer Lösung kommen auch wenn sie nicht
so sympathisch ist völkerrechtlich und
viel Ukraine hauptsache wir können uns
auf unseren entscheidenden Gegner
konzentrieren den geopolitischen Gegner
nämlich China
wie gesagt da geht scheint es zwar Lager
zu geben auch bei der Abrams Debatte
offenbar stehen da ja aussehen und
blinken also die beiden Minister außen
und Verteidigung auf der einen Seite und
haben sich am Ende durchgesetzt aber es
gab offenbar wie wir lesen immer wieder
auch von sulliv in Sicherheitsberater
und von burns die andere Haltung die man
nicht von daher ist das auch eine
Blackbox teilweise und wir alle suchen
uns sehr kleine Häppchen und versuchen
daraus einen ein halbwegsstimmiges Bild
zu Basteln eines dieser Häppchen die
sich ja auch noch in dieser Woche
ereignet haben ist die Äußerung Putins
zum Gedenktag an die Schlacht von
Stalingrad da hat er sich ja auch zum
momentanen Situation geäußert das ganze
mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg verglichen
wieder sei Russland von der Ideologie
des Narzissmus bedroht und von deutschen
Panzern
verfängt das in Russland
bin ich sehr dankbar dass sie mich nicht
zu China gefragt haben da
da wäre meine Kenntnisse Null also was
hier Putin sagen dass
Russland durch die Ideologie des
narzissens oder Neonazismus bedroht ist
der stimme ich dem Putin komplett zu
Russland ist in der Tat total bedroht
von der Ideologie des Neonazismus
komplett besessen von diesen
neonazistischen
dogmatischen Konzept sind da können Sie
vergleichen Sie reden von Adolf Hitler
und von Vladimir Putin dann finden sie
manchmal die eins zu eins parallel
momentan sie können auch die englischen
Ideen finden seit Jahren eigentlich wie
die heim ins Reich Ideologie mit der
Krim und dornbas und diese diese ganze
Sachen mit dem plutokratischen Westen
das von finanzkräften besessen ist und
da werden sehr oft auch Juden mit
gemeint
aber die Drohung in der Ukraine für
russische Soldaten die zuerst die keine
russische Soldat wäre von keinem
deutschen Panzer bedroht während der
russische Soldat nicht in der Ukraine
das ist sehr einfach also die
Bedrohung den russischen Soldaten durch
die deutschen Panzer oder durch die
amerikanischer Art der riesysteme werde
sofort aufhören wenn die Russen einfach
die Ukraine verlassen
ähm also es ist eine klare klassische
Verschiebung zwischen
Opfer und Täter also die Russen
präsentieren sich sehr gerne seit Jahren
als ob sie Opfer wären und sie greifen
an in diesem Deckmantel wir sind ein
Opfer müssen schlagen aber in Russland
werden natürlich solche Krisen gerne
gekauft weil die staatliche Propaganda
und das Fernsehen und die Medien alles
die die brainwaschen seit zwei
Jahrzehnten und die Russen für Glauben
natürlich gerne dass es der böse Westen
ist der die der der das erklärt haben
soll und jetzt Russland zerstören wird
gesagt dass es ein Glaube sei dass man
Russland auf dem Schlachtfeld besiegen
könnte wie beurteilen Sie das ist das
wie ist das Kräfteverhältnis gerade
Ukraine Russland
was wir sehen ist das Putin alles
versucht um die Schlappe des ersten
Versuchs auszubügeln also wir erleben
eine Kriegswirtschaft oder albaggonser
Wort arbeitet inzwischen 24 Stunden rund
um die Uhr um neue Panzer zu fertigen
wir wissen nicht wie stark putinen den
Mangel etwa an an Halbleitern
ausgleichen konnte um moderne Waffen zu
bauen das dauert sicher lange aber er
macht ja auch jetzt schon durch Masse
will das sehen wir im Bach Mut er
schickt ja gnadenlos 10000 in den Tod es
heißt inzwischen das bis zu 40.000
Gefängnis in sassen dieser wagner-armee
da ihr Leben gelassen hätten das sagt
Olga Romanova das ist eine Frau die sich
ziemlich gut kennt was dieses Szene
angeht also kurz um er versucht alles
mit Masse hinzukriegen und wir wissen
natürlich nicht ob die technische
Überlegenheit die wir inzwischen ja
teilweise auf ukrainischer Seite haben
ausreichen wird um diesen Sturm Angriff
der jetzt erwartet wird vielleicht erst
im März oder April wenn also der der
früher als Schlamm wieder getro ist und
die schweren Fahrzeuge besser fahren
können das wissen wir nicht ich weiß
nicht ob es Sergej zu lemony da mehr
weiß das ist für mich eine offene
Geschichte ja da hören sie und lesen Sie
täglich unterschiedlichste
Einschätzungen auch von klugen Militärs
aber es ist gefährlich das können wir
auf jeden Fall die beurteilen Sie das
Kräfteverhältnis und warum eigentlich
ist bachmut entscheidend in diesem
Kriegsverlauf naja also es ist natürlich
ja jede Prognose im Falle des Krieges
ist natürlich nur eine Möglichkeit und
es geht nur darum ob wir die die
Richtung richtig ähm benennen und wir
können nicht für die Monate
zitieren weil die Komponenten zu
kompliziert sind also zum Beispiel wie
viele Waffen geliefert sein werden wie
viele Munition der Munition besonders
die arteriemunition ist besonders
wichtig jetzt für die Ukraine was
gelingt es in Russland woher bekommen
sie jetzt Waffen also iranischen Drohnen
sind wahrscheinlich nicht weil das Thema
aber was liefert Nordkorea was liefert
China wird China überhaupt etwas liefern
also das wäre ein gamechanger
und so weiter und so fort vielleicht
gehen wir die Frage ganz kurz einmal an
Herrn Ski ist eine interessante Frage
wie verhält sich China wie verhält sich
Nordkorea also erstmal nordkorieren
Nordkorea das ist sehr aktiv Nordkorea
liefert jetzt konkret schon Munitionen
kanonengeschütze schon in großen Mengen
China zögert deutlich gerade mit Militär
Material mit Militärfahrzeugen aber
durchaus auch schon mit der sogenannte
double News Elementen also Elementen die
auch mediterisch genutzt werden können
z.B die Drohnen die normalerweise auch
für zivilen braucht eingesetzt werden
die sind im Einsatz auch für die für die
russischen Militärs China zögerte auch
deswegen weil aus der chinesischen
strategischen Überlegung eine zweite
Option denkbar wäre damit nämlich
deswegen Krieg sich in die Länge zieht
chinesischer Seite gut ja weil das ja
sowohl die Russen wie auch die Westen
anderen diesen Krieg bindet der Westen
wird nicht mehr den Kopf frei haben um
auf China zu gucken warum soll es nicht
passieren das war ja auch unter dem Mao
schon der Fall auch hatte er mit dem USA
verbündet um die Sowjetunion an
Europa zu binden das ist ihm sogar
soweit auch gelungen
versucht das gleiche also wenn Russland
Siegen könnte wunderbar wenn nicht dann
sollte der Kriege weiter dauern also
insofern denke ich ist die chinesische
Überlegung wir
Feinden dem besten nicht so weit ist der
beste nur noch zu uns kommen und die
Russen vergessen aber wir verfeinern den
den besten so weit dass die Russen
glauben wir sind hinter ihnen ja also
das ist so aber zurück zu ihrer Frage
also ob die Ukraine diese gewinnen
können ich glaube schon
wir sehen dass die Ukraine technisch
dank den unterschiedliche Hilfe ganz
überlegen den Russen sind
Moral ist viel Höhe die Russen haben
ihre beste Kräfte schon verloren den
ersten Monaten die Russen zeigen keine
Erfolge seit Monaten sie haben 40.000
Männer geopfert um vier bis fünf
Kilometer im Bereich bachmut
durchzukommen in den innerhalb der
letzten drei Monaten also das ist kein
Sieg was eine große Nation darstellen
könnte im Gegenteil die Ukraine haben
über
60%, welche die Russen seit Anfang
dieses Krieges und dieses große von
Siebe besetzt haben haben sie Ukraine
zurückgewonnen dabei war die
militärische Hilfe von Westen trotz
allem Heimat und Mars 2 und
Panzerhaubitze 2000 ganz kleinen winzig
klein also wir haben also nicht so die
USA haben unter 20 Heimat geschickt aus
ihren Beständen von glaube ich 1400 und
diese 20 Heimat plus weiß ich nicht so
zehn Mars und die andere Geräte
die haben die russische Armee geschlagen
stellen Sie sich vor also wenn wir jetzt
die
Ängste schwören die NATO wird in den
Krieg gezogen welche die NATO verliert
wir haben 1,7 Prozent von den allen
Kriegsausgaben den NATO in diesen Krieg
bisher investiert und haben 130.000
russische gefallen Soldaten und Rückzug
russische Armee und Russen haben Carson
verlassen und alle Gebiete in Chemie und
Kiefer lässt und die russische Armee ist
praktisch geschlagen mit 20 heimers was
passiert denn hier 100 schicken
natürlich klar diese Situation gerade
ist absolut bedrohlich und natürlich
kommt ja auch die Forderung auch noch
weitere Waffen zu liefern das heißt so
überlegen wie sie das jetzt gerade
schildern scheint die Situation ja doch
nicht zu sein aber wie schätzen Sie es
einfach ja es geht um den Faktor Zeit
wir spielen hier alle auf Zeit der Grund
warum es so eng wird um Bach mut ist
natürlich beide seitenversuchen vor
allen Dingen jetzt Versorgungswege
entweder zur sichern oder abzuschneiden
und da geht es jetzt um jede
nahtschnelle Stelle es ist fast schwer
nachzuverfolgen welche Zentimeter
Bewegungen hätte er nie Herz
angesprochen um die ist jetzt geht aber
für die Ukraine geht es darum dass
schwere Geschütz was sie jetzt
zugesichert bekommen haben so schnell
wie möglich zu bekommen und wir wissen
dass und herrlich schließers
angesprochen der Deal um die Abrams
Tanks die Abrams werden nicht bald
kommen sie werden in Monaten kommen oder
vielleicht in Jahren auch wenn wir jetzt
schon langsam das Gespräch aufnehmen
über die F16 ähm auch das könnte nicht
schnell kommen eine Ausbildung am F16
würde in einer rotationsausbildung 6
Monate dauern das heißt wir müssen im
Westen auch dafür Verantwortung
übernehmen dafür dass wir über den
kriegszeitraum auch eine Verantwortung
haben dann müssen wir uns auch darüber
Gedanken machen das heißt wir schneller
wir schweres Gerät liefern können und je
schneller wir uns wieder auf eine Linie
einigen können was wir liefern wollen
mit welchem expliziten Lieblingsziel für
unsere für die die NATO und den
westlichen Zusammenschluss in welcher
Weise wir welches genaue Kriegsziel der
Ukraine unterstützen wollen diese
Klarheit ist ganz enorm wichtig denn das
was herrischen geht schon angesprochen
hat die Russen versuchen natürlich
taktisch jetzt das zu tun was wir
natürlich schon lange praktizieren sich
nämlich in Anführungszeichen alliierte
heranzuholen wir haben kurz über den
Iran gesprochen und über China Iran und
Russland haben diese Woche ihr
Finanzsystem interessanterweise
zusammengelegt weil sie auch Swift
ausgeschlossen sind die Chinesen Üben
mit den Russen in an verschiedenen
Militärübungen wir haben überhaupt
Leiter und dual-news gesprochen wir
haben darüber gesprochen wie geht's der
russischen Wirtschaft im nächsten Jahr
der IWF sagt oh 2,1% Wachstum könnte
nächstes Jahr drin sein warum weil die
Türkei China Iran Kasachstan und alle
möglichen Tore für Russland immer gleich
auch noch mal im Detail zu ich würde
noch mal für einen Moment gerne bei den
Waffen bleiben da gibt's eine große
Sorge in der Bevölkerung rund einem
Drittel gehen laut dem aktuellen ARD
deutschland-trend die Waffenlieferung zu
weit und wir haben auch auf Twitter
jemanden der uns die Frage mitgibt wenn
man für Frieden Waffen braucht was
braucht man dann für Krieg also
vielleicht einfach noch mal die Frage in
den Raum gestellt ich möchte auch noch
ein bisschen Wasser in unser geheißen
das Thema Munition ist oder ein ganz
dramatisches das Lesen ja nicht jeder
Ecke wir können absehen dass die Ukraine
im Sommer spätestens im Herbst einfach
nicht mehr genug Munition hat um sich zu
wehren dann das Thema Sanktionen es gibt
gerade eine neue Studie der Universität
St Gallen wonach gerade mal 9% der
westlichen Firmen in Russland verlassen
haben 91% sind noch da Klammer auf die
meisten haben ihren Hauptsitz in
Deutschland
hat seine Prognosen korrigiert die
Wachstumsprognose der sagt jetzt
Russland wird ein Wachstum von 0,3%
haben noch vor kurzem das wird ein Minus
Wachstum von 2,3% kurz um Russland zeigt
sich zeigt sich als äußerst resilient
und auch geschickt im Umgehen von
Sanktionen da helfen wussten sie dass
Armenien dass da der Import von Handys
sich verzehnfacht hat das ist nicht weil
die Armenia so viel Geld in der Tasche
haben sondern natürlich sind das sind
das Reimporte nach Russland und die
Länder wie Kasachstan Türkei selbst
Kirgistan helfen alle tapfer mit um die
westlichen Sanktionen zu umgehen
also unsere Hoffnung wir können das auch
noch ökonomisch hinkriegen der wir
strangulieren Russland so sehr dass es
den Krieg gar nicht mehr finanzieren
kann das ist alles richtig on the long
run Russland Russland gerade gibt für
die Ölprodukte für die russischen
Ölprodukte also Heizöl Diesel das wirkt
ja seit heute das ist diesen Preis
Deckel gibt das im Barcode wird das was
verändern dass man jetzt auch den
Schritt auf die Produkte erweitert für
Öl galt das ja schon länger
die also wir haben also zuerst diese
Frage also
warum sollte man Waffen für für den
Frieden schicken das ist ja das ist so
Paradoxal und das kann ich Stimmen naja
das ist die Frage selbst die verdreht
die Realität also wir in der in
Deutschland wir haben nie für unseren
Frieden und unsere Freiheit mit Waffen
gekämpft das ist so die die Nationen
welche sie selbst traumatisiert hat also
wir kämpfen immer auf der falschen Seite
und der letzte kriegen den wir führten
das war der Krieg auf der Seite der
Nazis und dann natürlich hier je
schneller die deutschen Soldaten die
Waffen niederließen desto schneller kam
der Frieden aber der Frieden kam
deswegen weil die Alliierten kamen
welche den Frieden bringen wollten und
man verwechselt bei uns Frieden mit
Abwesenheit der Kämpfe und Abwesenheit
der Kämpfer ist kein Frieden da wenn die
Nazis geworden hätten dann wäre es in
Europa keine kämpfen mehr aber es ist
kein Frieden es wäre wird Sklaven es
werde Terror es werde genutzt werden ein
riesige aussieht Portugal bis bis nach
Brest und das ist der wesentliche
Unterschied zwischen dem Frieden und
abwesenden der Kämpfe da der Frieden ist
nur durch sorry für diese Banalität
durch den Sieg der guten erreichbar kann
und nicht durch den Sieg der bösen da
der singt der bösen ist kein Frieden
sondern sondern der Grab und deswegen
müssen wir Waffen liefern weil die
Ukraine nicht kämpfend weil sie es so
gerne mögen sondern weil sie den Frieden
erreichen werden erreichen wollen und
Frieden für die Ukraine und für uns ist
dass der aggresso da der schonistische
Putin zurückgedrängt wird und jetzt zum
Frage von von den ähm Bares und so
weiter ich glaube unsere Reaktion in
diesem Krieg war immer zu spät und zu
wenig zu spät mit Sanktionen zu wenig
Sanktionen zu spät mit den Waffen und zu
wenig Waffen und dann wurden wir wundern
wir uns warum das nicht funktioniert
natürlich also es ist jetzt die Frage
wer Steuern auf den 24 Februar hat die
innenpolitische Debatte in den USA
angesprochen es gibt die Kollegen wie
Michael mcford den früheren
amerikanischen Botschafter in Moskau der
sagt so am 24 Februar muss das Signal
kommen und zwar muss ein neues
waffenpaket stehen was der Westen vorher
abgesprochen hat da gehören auch
Luftfahrzeug also F16 müssen auch in
solche Diskussion es muss ein zehntes
Sanktionspaket es muss ein ganz starkes
Signal gesendet werden denn ein langer
Krieg kann ist in keinem Interesse sie
haben die öffentliche Meinung
angesprochen die sich in allen Ländern
dreht gerade in den USA hin jetzt zu
einer Präsidentschaftswahl das heißt die
USA hat eigentlich keinen Interesse an
einem langen Krieg und die Europäer ja
eigentlich auch nicht aber wenn das dann
die gemeinschaftliche Meinung ist dann
muss erstens das ganze noch mal globaler
gesehen werden sie haben die
rohölprodukte angesprochen dann muss mit
Indien anders verhandelt werden dann
muss mit anderen Abnehmern dieser
russischen Produkte anders verhandelt
werden
und es muss ein erweitertes
sanktionenpaket her es dürfen keine Olli
Garching den Flughafen Frankfurt haben
kaufen wie kann das passieren frage ich
mich und es müssen ganz andere Waffen in
einer unterschiedlichen Sequenzierung an
die Front in der Ukraine gebracht werden
die USA bereiten ja in den Tat auch so
einen Hilfspaket noch ein neues vor
Kampfjets noch nicht dennoch Peking hat
jetzt auch in dem Beziehung den Ton
verschärft schon vor dem mutmaßlichen
spionageballon und hat die USA schon
auch mitverantwortlich für den Krieg in
der Ukraine gemacht wie beurteilen Sie
eine solche Äußerung der Tonwechsel ist
natürlich ein sehr wichtiger Teil den
der Ton hat sich schon dreimal sehr
unterschiedlich gewechselt am Anfang war
es ja nur die Unterstützung für Russen
die fühlen sich auch zurecht wird
bedroht deswegen müssen sie sehr
zuschlagen und dann war es ein bisschen
Neutralität wir Chinesen wollen
eigentlich nur Frieden Frieden um jeden
Preis und die Ukraine wird auch nicht
mehr nicht so ganz verteufelt und jetzt
geht es wieder zurück die USA der Westen
sein Schulz dran aber das ist nur ein
Teil der anderen Teil der viel wichtiger
Teil ist ja in der Verzahnung der
militärischen Maschinen zwischen
Russland und China es waren ja zwei
gemeinsame
Patrouillenfahrten zwischen der
Pazifikflotte Russlands und chinesische
Marine Richtung
allusionsrichtung Alaska und auf einem
Rückweg hatten die beiden
Verbände zwei der japanische Insel
umkreist um abzuschrecken und jetzt gibt
es noch die Berichte die auch bestätigt
worden sind dass beide Luftwaffen sich
gegenseitig die Lizenz erteilt haben
ihre strategische Bomber in dem
jeweiligen Land stationieren zu können
oder landen zu können
diese Verzahnung die hat es vorher noch
nie gegeben gerade die Strate die
russischen strategische Bombe hatte eine
reich von mindestens 6000 km die
Chinesen noch nicht aber wenn sie
gemeinsam diese Reichweite haben dann
haben sie eine Schlagkraft auch in
pazifisch indischen Ozean das heißt also
es baut sich eine andere Szenario der
Spannung im fernen Osten auf vielleicht
nicht direkt um Taiwan herum auch wenn
so viele Menschen hier in Europa über
Taiwan sprechen sondern es baut sich
eigentlich in Nordost in Nordostasien
auf also Nordkorea schießt immer wieder
mal Raketen in Richtung südkorean droht
Japan und ja die japaner haben mir
eigentlich beschlossen 500
Körper von der Amerikanern zu kaufen sie
wollen diese diese Waffen
stationiert Wissen gegenüber der
Shanghai Wirtschaftsraum Chinas und also
die spannungsszenario im fernosten wird
hier nicht so weit thematisiert
aber die ist real die die nehmen die
jederzeit zu und auch europäische Mächte
bringen sich ein Großbritannien zum
Beispiel hat jetzt ein Militär Bündnis
mit Japan beschlossen das heißt also die
Stationierung britische Soldaten in
Japan wäre jetzt möglich japanischen
selbstverteidigungskräfte könnten
theoretisch auch in Großbritannien
stationiert sein aber das kommt gar
nicht in Frage es gibt jetzt eine
Repräsentanz Japans bei der NATO und das
geht jetzt weiter und ich denke für
Russland ist dieses Szenario willkommen
weil das in der Tat die westlichen
Aufmerksamkeit langfristig dauerhaft
woanders hin lenkt und das Fördern
natürlich auch solche Diskussionen
sollen wir den Krieg äh schnell beenden
und zu jetzt zu jeden Preis oder zu
einem bestimmten Preis wo die Ukraine
vielleicht dann doch gezwungen wird zu
sagen okay dann dann lass uns mal
verhandeln
lassen Sie uns mal wirklich noch mal
über genau diesen Punkt länger sprechen
das ist ja in der Tat das was passiert
wir haben jetzt seit einem Jahr diese
Situation so in der Ukraine das bindet
so wie sie es geschildert haben viele
Überlegungen viele Kräfte gleichzeitig
verschieben sich die Machtverhältnisse
es gibt die brix-staaten also Brasilien
Russland in China und Südafrika die ja
auch noch mal zusammen Überlegung
anstellen was verschiebt sich da gerade
unbemerkt also zuerst man muss das das
wird in Deutschland gar nicht diskutiert
das ist besonders sichtbar wenn man viel
in zentrale und osteopor unterwegs ist
ist
zum Beispiel ich machen und ich war zum
letzten Mal in der Ukraine direkt an der
Frontlinie praktisch so 20 km von der
Frontlinie vor drei Wochen und in Polen
auch und wenn man von dort aus sieht uns
an da versteht man das wir in einem in
einem macht leben welche eine
bald nicht mehr so mächtig wird also
Deutschland befindet sich auf einer
stabilen aber unstoppbaren Talfahrt also
wir verlieren wirtschaftlich wir haben
schon
immens moralisch verloren also unser
Image ist ruiniert also wir wollen uns
selbst
also einlullen des wir Friedensengel
sind dass wir so besonnen sind dass wir
so ausgewogen sind wir haben unser Image
in Osteuropa verspielt und zerstört
teilen Sie das und stoppbar geht's
bergab vielleicht dass der letzte Punkt
und dann kann es weiter kommentiert
werden also das sehen uns so sehen uns
unsere Nachbar an und die ignorieren uns
und die werden uns dann noch mehr
ignorieren weil wir für Sie für die
Polen für die Ukraine eine Nation der
sorry dumme nix mache sind und die Polen
kaufen jetzt Waffen und die Ukraine
werden wie sie die Russen schlagen
können und wissen dass die Deutschen
glaubten dass die Ukraine nie Russen
schlagen werden können und wir können
haben es gemacht glaube ich jetzt an der
Stelle mal kurz in die Runde geben was
wir offensichtlich nicht vermögen aus
Berlin ist eine strategische eine in
strategische Vorleistung zu gehen wir
haben es jetzt eben schon angesprochen
die Amerikaner gucken natürlich sehr
weit in die Welt das heißt wenn ein
niederländischer Regierungschef und sein
Außenminister bei an beiden sitzen und
über Halbleiter sprechen wenn ein
japanischer Regierungschef überhaupt
Leiter spricht dann hat das auch sehr
wohl mit der Ukraine zu tun und es hat
sehr wohl damit zu tun wie könnte wie
überlegt eine USA wie müssten Sie im
Zweifel in einem zwei Fronten Krieg
reagieren wir wollen wir wünschen uns
oder würden uns von den Europäern
wünschen dass sie anfangen zu überlegen
nicht erst also dass wir Lehren ziehen
aus dem was in Russland gerade passiert
ist nämlich wenn wir versuchen unsere
wirtschaftsströme oder wenn sie
plötzlich abkoppeln müssten weil China
in Taiwan a reagiert welche Auswirkungen
hätte das auf das wohlstands- und
Wirtschaftssystem Europa und Deutschland
wie sitzen wir da am strategischen
Reisbrett wir sehen wir sehen auch wie
sich das im Iran noch mal ganz klar
auswirkt ja wir haben schon besprochen
die militärischen Zusammenhänge die
finanziellen Zusammenhänge was ist denn
nun mit dem iranischen
atomabkommen wenn Russland mit einmal
sich beschließt mit den Iranern in
Anführungszeichen gemeinsamer Sache zu
machen das new Startup kommen was das
einzig noch existente nuklearabkommen
auf der Welt ist das läuft 20 das läuft
in in 2026 aus und ist jetzt schon nicht
mehr wird jetzt schon quasi nicht mehr
ist nicht mehr nutzbar also wir haben
ganz große geostrategische Sorge die
Amerikaner mit orkes und verschiedenen
anderen Koalitionen ziehen versuchen
eine Welt zusammenzuziehen sie tun es
unter dem ähm ja unter dem Nomen
Demokratien gegen Autokratien nicht gut
gewählt der Meinung nach aber wir in
Europa scheinen immer noch dem dem
geostrategischen dem diopolitischen aber
er braucht dem geoökonomischen in der
Planung zu weit hinterher zu hängen da
müssen wir dringend nachbessern
ja das sehe ich ganz genauso ich
erinnere mich deutlich an 1994 da wurde
ich Korrespondentin Brüssel und war
spontan sehr entsetzt als ich diesen in
sich zerrissenen Haufen erleben musste
wo viele nationale Egoismen sich dann zu
ganze halbgaren und faulen Kompromissen
mendelten das ist lange Zeit später
nicht besser geworden wenn sie mal
schauen wer die Ukraine gerettet hat vor
den vor dem russischen Angriff das sind
die USA vollstopp das ist ein Krieg vor
unserer Haustür unserer europäischen und
wenn sie die Zahlen mal anschauen ist
das nicht sehr sympathisch wenn sie dann
noch mal gucken wer hat denn was
geliefert und setzen das ein Relation
zum Motor Inlandsprodukt dann sind die
stolzen reden in Berlin auch ziemlich
holen denn da liegen wir am Platz 12 13
also ich habe gerade in der Statistik
gesehen Anteil 0,05 bis 0,15 das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt da liegt
Deutschland ja also die die tapferen
baltischen Staaten und auch die Polen
sind dunkelblau gefärbt die haben
deutlich mehr investiert wenn Sie dieses
Trauerspiel anschauen die starke Achse
Paris Berlin wo ist sie denn es gab eine
kleine Feier mit zusammengebissenen
Zähnen und das war es auch schon wir
haben einen deutschen Bundeskanzler der
nicht meiner Lage oder bereit ist ein
klares Ziel zu formulieren und diese
paternalistische Rede im Bundestag so
die Klang also liebe Kinder ja ich sage
euch nicht was ich vorhabe aber glaubt
mir bestimmt es wundervoll ab und das
ist eine ganz tolle Entscheidung auch
das ist ja richtig hohl wenn sie mal ein
bisschen lesen das jetzt noch nicht mal
genug Länder auf marschieren die Leo
zwei überhaupt liefern wollen ja das war
offenbar in keinster Weise sorgfältig
vorher abgestimmt und und abgesprochen
die kommen wir auf diese beiden
Bataillons glaube ich wenn man Bilder
wie viel die man insgesamt ich habe es
vergessen 44 war mal geplant jetzt
runter gemeldet und diese Zahl von Leo 2
das ist ja nichts wenn sie gerade mal
Einsatz mal gerade mal nachlesen was
Alex geschrieben hat das ist ja sehr
Militär der USA
vorne Vers war es glaube ich der auch
sicherheitsratsmitglied war also kein
sage ich mal keinen Spinner der hat ganz
klar aufgezeigt wir müssten wenn wir
diesen Krieg schnell beenden wollten so
viel Waffen liefern dass die Ukraine es
schafft den landkorridor haben also auch
schon mehr abzuschneiden und die Krim
glaubhaft zu bedrohen dann wäre Putin an
dem Punkt wo er Abschied nimmt von
seinen visionären verrückten Obsessionen
und dann müsste verhandeln ja aber davon
sind wir Lichtjahre entfernt sind wir
davon Lichtjahre entfernt also es ist ja
die Einschätzung jetzt die kommenden
sechs Monate entscheidend sein werden
für den Ausgang des Krieges wie ich
glaube schon wegen wegen äh die Ukraine
also sind schon jetzt in der Lage diese
Sommer von 7 anzufangen die Frage ist
nur wie viele wie viele Verluste die
Ukraine dabei leiden und man muss auch
sagen jeder Tag unsere Debatten und
unsere Verzögerung und die die in die
Zukunft verschobene Ausbildung der
ukrainischen privaten bezahlen die
Ukraine mit mit ihrem Blut also jeder
Tag der Verzögerung kostet dann Ukraine
Menschenleben und das Sterben die besten
und das wird uns nie vergessen werden
also das muss den Leuten in Berlin klar
sein das wird uns nie vergessen werden
die Ukraine werden uns nie verzeihen und
wir können während diesen Krieg gewinnen
und uns nie verzeihen dass wir sie
praktisch verraten haben mit unserem
Gerät und dann komme ich zurück zu und
Sie werden diesen Korridor bauen mit
diesen Kosten und mit anderen und wir
haben die Russen aus ihrem Land für
vertreiben also nur die Frage ist im
Sommer oder im Winter und so weiter das
werden sie machen die Frage ist wir
bildet jetzt für unsere Tür im Osten
eine allianze der Länder Ukraine
basischen Staaten Slowakei Tschechien
und Ukraine auch und die verstehen jetzt
die verstehen ihre Kraft die füllen
beflügelt weil sie plötzlich sich
agieren sie sind die Macherinnen und Sie
sehen dass sie jetzt die Sachen so
können welche wir uns Deutschen nicht
machen können und wir trauen uns gar
nicht darüber zu denken in Berlin
versteht das nicht und man versteht das
auch nicht dass man in Osteuropa zentral
Europa mehr Deutschland wünschte die
ganze Zeit es ging nicht darum dass die
Polen uns wegschieben wollten es ging
darum dass die Polen und die Ukraine
mehr deutsche Panzer sehen wollen
stimmen
wollen ob sie die Analyse Teilen ganz
kurz ob das aus ihrer Sicht vielleicht
auch mal so mit ein bisschen Blick wie
man es in Asien beurteilen würde ist
Deutschland ist Europa da in dieser so
schwachen Position
eine ein Teil der Führerschaft innerhalb
der EU verliert das ist schon wahr und
das ist eigentlich nicht besonders im
Interesse Chinas man wünscht sich in
Deutschland mit dem man dann einige
Sachen abreten verabreden kann und dann
gilt es für die ganze EU das stimmt
jetzt nicht mehr wir haben Recht die aus
Europa die Südosteuropa driften von
Deutschland ab auf Frankreich ist keine
große Säule mehr wenn also diese beiden
Mittelmächte in Europa ihre
führerschafter einbüßen während des
Krieges in der Ukraine dann hat Tina in
Deutschland in Europa kaum noch jemand
anzusprechen aus Europa ist sowieso
schon weg diese Seitenstraße ist mit
Europa nicht mehr zu machen zumindest
nicht mit mit dem Osten mit dem Süden
auch nicht mehr
aber das gemischte Gefühl in in china
ist ja vielleicht ist es umso besser
wenn Europäer miteinander nicht sich
einigen können wenn sie die USA
quasi von Tinten auch ein bisschen
ausbremsen können und dann wird der
Krieg länger länger und warum auch nicht
das andere ist allerdings dass diese
europäische Länder sich immer mehr in du
pazifische Raum einmischen also
Frankreich zum Beispiel ist jetzt ein
sehr aktiver Partner für die in der
pazifische Strategie von der USA Japan
der der deutsche Luftwaffen general
fliegt persönlich eine Eurofighter nach
Tokio und sagte wir stehen ganz fest auf
der Europäer japanischen Seite das heißt
also es ist nicht so dass die Europäer
nur sagen wir kommen aus nur um den um
den Krieg in der Ukraine es kann ja auch
als Szenario sein dass sie sagen okay
Ukraine überlassen werden in den USA wer
zahlt nur unser Tribut in passieren da
wird es so schnell keinen Krieg geben
wir sind immer noch Friedensengel wir
Bekunden unseren Willen zu kooperieren
okay die Chinesen werden bloß ein
bisschen übel nehmen aber sie wissen
dass wir eigentlich Tiger ohne Zähne
sind okay
[Musik]
und ich denke das ist auch deswegen so
gefährlich weil die Deutschen oder auch
nicht nur die deutschen Franzosen
langsam auch dass sie immer noch in
dieser ökonomistische Denkweise
verharren und sagen solange die
Wirtschaft funktioniert alles aber die
Wirtschaft funktioniert nicht mehr die
chinesische Wörter funktioniert auch
nicht mehr so ganz insofern ist also ein
Umdenken in Deutschland auch in in eine
globalen Ausmaß absolute von Nöten also
es ist nicht nur wegen der Ukraine auch
wegen der Ukraine ach auch wegen
deutscher Rolle den Deutschland ohne
eine Führerschaft in der Hand die Idee
zählt eigentlich weltweit hat so viel
das ist ja in der Tat gerade so dass man
das Gefühl bewegt sich ganz viel es gibt
ja auch noch die Analyse der RAND
Corporation in USA eine Denkfabrik die
gesagt hat ein absoluten Sieg könne es
nicht geben und ein langer Krieg sei
nicht im amerikanischen espresse von
daher müsste man vielleicht an
Waffenstillstand oder Verhandlungen
denken sind denn Bedingungen dafür
überhaupt gerade vorhanden nein
kurze Antwort
ob das jetzt stimmt dieser diese letzte
burns Initiative oder auch nicht aber
sie müssen ja nur mal sich die Sache
angucken was sagt Putin was macht Putin
nein putin ist fest davon überzeugt
durch einen Kraftakt genau wie Stalin
Zweiten Weltkrieg ja durch den Einsatz
immenser Mengen egal was das kostet
diesen Krieg zu gewinnen Punkt da gibt's
keinen noch nicht bei den Hauch einer
einer Idee wie könnte der mal jetzt
verhandeln sein ich Haltestelle und
zuletzt geben mein Gott der Mann
befeuert jeden Tag aufs Neue versucht
ein Land zusammenzuhalten das genau weiß
was passieren würde wenn es kopiert wird
ich meine wie viel Dutzend Folterkeller
sind bereits entdeckt worden wie viel
tausend Geschichten haben wir jetzt
gehört darüber was die Besatzungskräfte
tun die russischen ja
das kann ich das nicht erkennen also es
hat ja nie das ärgert mich an der ganzen
Debatte wir haben hier einen wachsenden
Teil der deutschen Bevölkerung der sagt
keine Waffenlieferanten wir müssen viel
mehr Energie in diplomatische Bemühungen
stecken das ist eine so billige
ausweiche Idee das kann ich Ihnen sagen
oder nein ich hoffe
Therapeut aber schauen Sie eine Zahl ist
ja die hast du auch glaube ich
getwittert das ja glaube ich fast 80% im
westlichen Teil Deutschland sind für
Sanktionen oder sogar eine Verschärfung
von Sanktionen daraus können wir ja
ableiten das sind Menschen die können
zwischen Gut und Böse unterscheiden also
das sind da gibt's eine große Mehrheit
andererseits schrumpft aber der Teil der
Bach weitere Waffenlieferungen
befürwortet und es steigt der Anteil
derer die sie nicht wollen
und das ist auch verständlich dahinter
steckt eine Angst natürlich diese
sogenannten roten Linien zu
überschreiten das erleben wir die werden
immer neu gezogen Schützenpanzer dann
Kampfpanzer jetzt Flugzeuge was ich für
eine absurde Geschichte halte das ist
wirklich eine Panzerhaubitze schießt
genauso Menschen tot wie an Leoparden
Zweifelsfall diese roten Linien sind
psychologische vielleicht bestenfalls
aber keine logischen Kennzahl und ja und
das macht aber Potenz große Hoffnung aus
warum befeuert Putin die Angst vor
atomkriegt nicht nur in seinen
unsagbaren Talkshow sondern auch selbst
warum sagte in Sätze wie es ist deutlich
besser als Held für das Vaterland zu
sterben denn am Vodka zugrunde zu gehen
also unabhängig davon dass es mit
ziemlich
erfrischend realistische Schilderung der
russischen lebenswahrscheinlich behalten
sind aber das sind alles Bemühungen das
Volk
aufzurufen zum zur Bereitschaft fürs
Vaterland zu sterben ne aber das gelingt
Gott sei Dank auch nicht weil die ganze
ist eher unpolitisch apathisch und sehr
opportunistisch das ist jetzt mal die
gute Nachricht ich jetzt hier als
düsterer Verkünder immer nur
unangenehmer Wahrheiten
kommen und hinzuhören vielleicht noch
mal kurz Stefan Geier der auf Twitter
fragt wie kann man in Russland und bei
Putin und seinem Umfeld eine
Bereitschaft zum Rückzug Russlands aus
der Ukraine denn erzeugen also bei Herrn
Putin mit auf keinen Fall das hatte ich
im Vorfeld schon auf total gesagt ich
glaube das ist genau richtig wir
herrlich schließt das beschreibt wir
haben über die Allianzen gesprochen die
er sich sucht wir haben über das
innenpolitische Umfeld gesprochen was er
sich sucht ich will nur einen Hinweis
noch machen die nuklear Drogen sind
bislang nichts geworden und auch dann im
Youtube destruction besteht ja immer
noch das heißt es wäre eine Nuklearwaffe
eine kurze Range Nuklearwaffe auf der
Territorium der Ukraine was macht das
mit den Ukraine die kämpfen noch härter
und wir sind noch schneller dabei das
lohnt sich also nicht alles andere was
wir uns schon ausgemalt haben
biologische Waffen chemische Waffen
alles bislang nicht passiert sollte man
in Erinnerung behalten wenn wir darüber
nachdenken wie könnte es jetzt
weitergehen oder sind diese Drohungen
wirklich kann man mit den Drohungen
sollte man mit den Drohungen arbeiten
aber die Bevölkerung das ist einen
wirklicher Punkt denn was Herrn Putin
gefreut haben wird ist dass dieser Krieg
dazu führt dass wir jetzt wirklich ein
splinter.net ein technologischen
Eisernen Vorhang zwischen Russland
Russland China auf der einen Seite und
dem besten auf der anderen Seite haben
das heißt wir haben eine russische
Bevölkerung die aus unserer
Argumentation und aus unserer Sichtweise
des Krieges nichts mehr mitbekommt und
so haben auch amerikanische Strategen
argumentiert wir müssen viel mehr Geld
in die konterinformationen streuen denn
genauso wird Herr Putin natürlich mit
allen Waffen inklusive der
Desinformation der Beeinflussung der
Türkei weiterhin daran arbeiten dass wir
Europäer uns selbst aneinander
abarbeiten gibt es wahrscheinlich auch
ganz viele Zuschauer Fragen deswegen sie
können Sie bestimmt gleich auch noch mal
in die Richtung Antworten hören wir doch
mal was rein hat oder aus Wedel eine
Frage hat guten Morgen ja hallo guten
Morgen die Waffenlieferungen und die
materiale materielle Unterstützung in
der Ukraine ist natürlich wichtig aber
viel wichtiger ist ja die Heimatfront
sozusagen in Russland mal zu bedenken
was tut der Westen aktiv
um die Informationslage in Russland in
der russischen Bevölkerung zu verbessern
die Medien sind ja alle gleichgeschaltet
und welche Möglichkeiten haben wir im
Westen die russische Bevölkerung zu
informieren Dankeschön
also es gibt einige Initiative oder
zuerst vielen Dank für Ihre Frage es
gibt viele Initiativen seitens der EU
die unabhängigen Medien zu schaffen und
zu finanzieren welche den Rüstung Russen
die objektive Informationen in russische
Sprache anbieten sollten ich persönlich
finde diese Initiativen wenig praktisch
warum also man kann ein paar hundert
Millionen Euro investieren das wird
nicht schaden aber ich glaube nicht dass
sie sehr positiv einwirken können warum
zuerst auch vor diese großen Version
hatten die Russen fast uneingeschränkt
Zugang zu russischsprachigen westlichen
Medien Deutsche Welle BBC äh also voice
of America Radio Liberty you name it und
deshalb nicht jetzt mit der Abschottung
des Internets können die Russen Kreml
alles abschalten also die Russen
bekommen Haftstrafen für
einfache likes im Facebook von solchen
von solchen Postings Facebook Twitter
sind abgeschaltet und was will wichtiger
ist Russland ist eine autoritäre wenn
nicht totalitäre das ist die Toilette
System wo die einfache Leute fast keinen
Einfluss mehr auf die Regierung haben
das heißt was sie dort meinen was sie
denken ist für Putin nicht relevant das
einzige was relevant ist ob die
russische Armee mit bloße Kraft aus der
Ukraine zurückgeschoben wird zurück
zurück gepusht wird und dann kann Putin
nicht mehr auch in seinem
bleigeschalteten Fernsehen den Russen
erklären dass er angeblich die Ukraine
kontrolliert und dann können die Russen
die Fragen stellen aber nicht weil wir
im Voice of Germany oder sowas in sagen
Putin sei schlecht danke schön für die
Antwort und wir hören mal was Frida
Meier aus
Bietigheim-Bissingen für eine Frage hat
guten Tag guten Tag hallo an alle in der
Runde guten Morgen war
ja wir hören sie gut ja und zwar habe
ich eine Frage es wird alles nur über
Waffenlieferung diskutiert und ganz
wenig über den Frieden und ich denke
dass man mit einer Diskussion über den
Frieden vielleicht mal darüber
nachdenken soll das Ganze zu beenden und
nicht noch mehr Waffen zu liefern das
bringt nämlich nichts
herrlich ist sie der Zuschauerin
Antworten ja ich habe es glaube ich eben
schon mal versucht deutlich zu machen
ich selbst habe eine russische Familie
ich habe russische Töchter die haben
russische Pässe ich vermisse meine
russische Familie und habe viele Freunde
in Russland auch in der Ukraine ich
wünschte mir nichts mehr als eine Fähre
realistische Chance auf Frieden das
müssen wir einfach glauben das ist mein
ganz privat Interesse ich würde gerne
mal wieder hinfahren und mit meinem
Schwiegervater in die waren ja gehen ja
so einfach ist das also ich habe
überhaupt null Interesse daran dass wir
diese Situation haben wenn es auch nur
so eine Chance gäbe an der erkennbare
mit Putin irgendwie irgendwas zu reden
das Frieden bringt wäre ich der
allererste der das tun würde aber ich
sehe es einfach nicht und ich kenne auch
keinen halbwegs gebildeten Experten der
so einen Weg aufzeigt das ist das
Problem da ist ein Mann mit einer
Obsession der ein ein fremdes Land
überfallen und und vernichten will auch
kulturell
die einzige Chance auf Frieden das kann
ich ihnen zugeben wäre die wir sagen der
Ukraine wir vergessen euch bitte lasst
euch doch von Russland erobern und guckt
was passiert Hauptsache und dann ist das
ein so zynischer Frieden da würde ich
nicht mitgehen schauen Sie diesen Weg
kann ich nicht mitgehen und darum müssen
wir leider den einzig realistischen und
pragmatischen gehen und das heißt
schneller modernere Waffen liefern damit
Putin wirklich an dem Punkt kommt zu
erkennen ich schaffe es nicht erst dann
wird er verhandelt erst dann kommt das
was sie so gerne möchten nämlich Frieden
treibt ganz viele Zuhörer und
Zuschauerinnen um hören wir mal was
Frank Knut aus Berlin für eine Frage hat
ja schönen guten Tag danke
Chinesen kommen soll ist das nicht nur
ein Zeichen von Chinesen für die
westliche Welt für die Amerikaner wir
sind da sondern vielleicht auch
indirektor Putin Russland zu zeigen das
sind nicht mehr der kleine Partner
sondern wir sind auf Augenhöhe und wir
sind dabei euch zu überholen und wenn
wir in Zukunft zusammenarbeiten
ist das jetzt nicht mehr so dass wir nur
auf euch hören sondern ihr müsst mir auf
uns hören und das sassenzeichen von
Putin auch indirekt an Bezeichnung von
dem Ski auch indirekt am putin war um
uns zu zeigen wer hier derjenige ist der
das Sagen hat halten Sie gerne eine
kurze Antwort weil wir ganz viele Fragen
haben eindeutig ich habe am Anfang schon
gesagt die Handlungsfähigkeit in
globalen Ausmaßen das geht natürlich ja
auch an die Adresse Moskau nicht nur wer
dann die senior partner ist oder
Juniorpartner sondern wenn ihr auf
unsere Hilfe rechnet dann müsste hier
auch in eine fairen Preis zahlen z.B in
den pazifische Regionen die gemeinsame
Erklärung ähm zweiten februar vor einem
Jahr weil er so dass China Russland bei
dem Krieg in der Ukraine unterstütze
Russland China bei der Blockade von
innenpazifische Strategie russland hat
bisher aus verständlichen Gründen nichts
gemacht oder gar nicht oder sehr wenig
insofern
haben sie errichtet dass das dieses
Zeichen nicht nur für die USA für den
Westen bestimmt ist auch für Moskau nur
ist es die Frage ob es jetzt ein
feindliches Signal ist oder ob das ein
wirklich nur ein Signal ist ihr seid die
Juniorpartner sondern ihr müsste
eigentlich uns mehr entgegenkommen und
wir gehen nach Köln zu Wolf-dieter
Zimmermann guten Tag ja einen schönen
guten Tag ich möchte mich zuerst einmal
für die Bemerkung von beide von dem
Herrn bedanken der links von ihnen sitzt
der gesagt hat Frieden ist mehr als die
Abwesenheit von Krieg das ist in unserem
Land leider Gottes nicht mehr so richtig
in den Köpfen der Menschen drin
bezogen auf die Waffen auf die Panzer
ich befürchte dass diese Panzer viel zu
spät kommen
es ist spätestens im Spätsommer klar
gewesen dass es irgendwann
Panzerlieferungen gibt und jetzt fängt
man an 180 Leo 1 vorzubereiten die ohne
weiteres kammface sind wann bitte sollen
die denn da sein bei der russischen
Parade wenn der Krieg vorbei ist das
halte ich für ein ganz ganz schlimmes
Versäumnis und ich befürchte die
Geschichte wird da über uns einmal ein
schlechtes Urteil bilden danke schön
danke für Ihre Noob und ich stimme Ihnen
komplett zu und ihre Ängste talen auch
fast alle Ukraine können mit welchen
nicht Sprache dass die Panzer zu spät
kommen und das eigentlich alle Waffen zu
spät kommen also wir haben zu spät mit
der Ausbildung begonnen wir haben zu
spät diese Entscheidung getroffen wir
haben zu spät geliefert oder noch gar
nicht geliefert und das kostet dann
Ukraine leben hier möchte ich an der
Stelle betonen wir befanden uns als
Fallschirm die ich als eingebürgerte
deutscher ich mir tut es sehr weh weil
ich dieses Land bewusst gewählt habe als
meine Heimat und ich brenne für dieses
Land und meine Kinder sind die Deutschen
die hier lieben in diesem Land und ich
wünsche Ihnen nur das Beste wir haben
eine historische einzigartige
glücksschanze verpasst zum ersten Mal
saß man ins in Ländern zentralen
Osteuropas auf Deutschland an und sagte
wir wollen die Deutschen Panzersoldaten
und Panzer oder Panzer hier sehen
stellen Sie sich vor wie wie einzigartig
es war in Polen und in der Ukraine
schaute man auf Deutsch und sagte
schickt an uns bitte Panzer die
deutschen Panzer wären als ein
friedensymbol als was was gewünschtes
Gesicht und wir haben diese Schanze
verpasst wir werden hoffentlich das
nachholen aber ich stimme ihm vollkommen
zu zu spät wird es auf jeden Fall sein
ich hoffe nicht sehr spät
und Holger Voss in Berlin ihre Frage
bitte
wie beurteilt der internationale
Frühschoppen die Aussage von Russische
Föderation Außenminister Säge la France
wir sind auf alles vorbereitet also im
Zusammenhang mit den Traktion
beispielsweise
gegen Moskau
ja also das die Russen versuchen zu
signalisieren sie können alles mögliche
zurückdrängen ist klar sie haben bereits
verschiedene Verträge mit Indien laufen
es gibt andere Länder die immer noch
sehr sehr dringend während ihre wegen
ihres eigenen Wirtschaftswachstums quasi
russisches Öl aber zum Teil auch im
russisches Gas noch brauchen da muss die
internationale Gemeinschaft ganz ganz
dringend nachsteuern aber alles das was
Russland gesagt hat womit Sie uns weiter
drohen wollen mit möglichen Cyber
Anschlägen auf unsere kritische
Infrastruktur mit möglichen abdrehen
verschiedener anderer Versorgungswege
mit einem ständigen Zünglein an der
Waage was unsere
Nahrungsmittelsicherheit angeht durch
den Hafen von Odessa das werden sie
alles probieren das ist richtig darauf
müssen auch wir vorbereitet sein im
Westen das heißt wir müssen in diesen
ganzen Fragen diese Herausforderung
sehen und diesen vorgreifen auf dass das
was sehr gelaufen sagt in keiner Weise
der Wahrheit entspricht
danke und Hans Goebbels aus Niederkassel
Ihre Frage guten Tag ja guten Tag in die
Runde
vielleicht habe ich einen Gedanken es
gibt ja keine Denkverbote in Deutschland
vielleicht ist mein Gedanke sehr abwegig
aber ist nicht vielleicht Olaf Scholz
der ganz große Stratege der noch darüber
nachdenkt es gibt ja auch mal eine
Nachkriegszeit und dann stände er
wahrscheinlich je nachdem wer gewinnt
besser da wenn er sagen könnte ich habe
immer gebremst aber ich wurde überstimmt
vom Westen
das war eigentlich ist das so
spannendes Szenario da gehe ich gerne
drauf ein Scholz macht also das was er
jetzt getan hat weiterhin und geht sehr
zögerlich nur mit Waffen nach vorne
lässt sich treiben gibt so wenig wie er
eben kann die Russen schaffen es in der
Tat die Ukraine in die Knie zu zwingen
wir haben also ein Russland jetzt an den
Grenzen zu Polen stehen wir haben einen
Putin der wahrscheinlich dann nicht sich
zurücklehnt und sagt danke das reicht
sondern er hat ja schon angekündigt auch
Moldau ist ein Thema und es geht weiter
werden eine explosive hoch riskante
Situation und in dem Moment ruft dann
herr Scholz bei Putin an und sagt aber
Wladimir du erinnerst dich ich habe doch
sehr wenig geliefert weil ich das mir
nicht verderben wollte mit dir und
können wir jetzt mal ein bisschen die
Dividende kriegen dafür ist das ein
Szenario was er ernsthaft erwähnen dass
wir dann sagen alles wieder prima
Ukraine ist weg aber jetzt machen wir
wieder handelt und verdienen prächtig
gegenseitig am waren und und und die ist
Leistungs Austausch ist das was Sie was
Ihnen vorschwebt
so danke dafür und Hans-jürgen Bauer aus
Troisdorf
einen guten Morgen in
die rotbich möchte einen ganz anderes
Szenario aufbauen was meines Erachtens
sehr wichtig ist aber ich habe es noch
nie eine ganze Zeit angesprochen gesehen
und zwar
eine ganz große Gefahr sehe ich in der
Zusammenarbeit
Erdogans mit Putin die Türkei ist in der
NATO hochrangige türkische
Militärs sitzen dort in den
führungsstäben und bekommen alles alles
was die NATO in irgendeiner Art und
Weise in diese Richtung hin
Unternehmen will bekommen Sie
rechtzeitig mit und wie das Verhältnis
zwischen Erdogan und Putin ist ich
glaube kaum dass man darüber sprechen
muss ob sie diese Befürchtung auch
teilen das wir faktisch über Erdogan an
Putin verraten werden könnten wir sehen
hier schon Kopfnicken mit der Türkei
oder bzw Herr Erdogan spielt ein ganz
ganz toxisches aber für ihn sehr
schlaues taktische Spieler hat im Mai
eine große Wahl und die bei dies um
seine politische Zukunft geht aber er
hat eben schon früher mit der NATO
gespielt der hat das S400 Abwehrsystem
der Russen gekauft als NATO Mitglied
schon ein großes Problem für die
nordatlantischen Partner und der spielt
natürlich jetzt auch mit dem Eintritt
von Schweden und Finnland der
Mitgliedschaft in der NATO seine eigenen
innenpolitischen Spielchen aus und
liefert das haben wir in der Sendung
besprochen weiterhin wirklich
wirtschaftliches Gerät und
wirtschaftsströme quasi offene
wirtschaftsstraßen an Russland das heißt
hier haben wir ein klassischen dual
Player in der Türkei das heißt es gibt
zwei wichtige Daten das Datum im Mai die
Wahlen und das Datum im Juli da sollen
Schweden und Finnland in die NATO
aufgenommen werden und es ist für die
NATO jetzt sehr wichtig in diesem zu
diesem Gipfel eine quasi eine Klausel
ein Passus sich zu überlegen der dafür
sorgen könnte wie könnte man überprüfen
wann ein solcher Staat wie die Türkei
die Grenzen übertreten hat wann kann man
und das hat die NATO in dem Sinne nicht
ähm einen Mitgliedstaat ausschließen und
welche Auswirkungen würde es dann wieder
geopolitisch geostrategisch in diesem
wichtigen geografischen Teil der Welt
haben Türkei schwierig danke vor allen
Dingen auch für die ganzen Fragen und
das engagierte teilnehmen an unserer
Sendung geschaffen leider nicht noch
weitere Fragen aber ich bedanke mich
beim Zuschauen und ZuhörerInnen bei
meiner Runde für die angenehme
interessante Diskussion und wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Sonntag
[Musik]